question for you boys uh because we've
been living here for a year now
what's the how long are you gonna be
staying here for do you think that's the
question i want to ask you too
what's what's what's my five year plan
[Music]
was a [ __ ] liar chris board said he
was only gonna live here for like five
years and he's
and he's still here he's been here
[ __ ] like years i think
[ __ ] i mean i'm approaching my fifth
year i mean time just moves [ __ ]
fast it doesn't even feel like i've been
here a year i i thought
yeah i'll live here for like two years
max i'm halfway through i'm just like
i've hardly even spent any time here
right
yeah i mean yeah that's the thing like i
i always thought to myself i'm like
i thought about i was like oh my god
i've been for almost five years
like yeah like moved out like moved out
of my parents and like actually lived in
japan on my own i was like
it does not feel like five years which
is why like which is why like the
question of like
what do you see yourself doing in five
years it's starting to sound less and
less absurd to me
because back you know when i was in my
teenage years and people were like
where do you see yourself in five years
five years so far you'd be doing
something [ __ ] different every year
yeah back at that age
but now it just feels like it's you you
can have like a different
routine and monotonous now we just sound
old now
i mean we are man we are depending on
how long well a big
[ __ ] question mark obviously is you
know how long will
geeks plus allow us to be here because
we're yeah mainly yeah mainland
i i'm i'm not calling you out right now
how long so i'm gonna i'm gonna say that
i'm gonna say this louder so it all
depends on how
how long geek's supposed to be around
because our visa depends on geeks plus
so this wow this is where it takes so
many [ __ ] sponsors by the way
we can give geeks plus money so that we
can satiate our
[ __ ] like laws overlords they're like
how many sponsors can we fit can an
episode
say no more adorable doable man i mean
okay but but i mean like
like the question though i think and
this is kind of goes back to the root of
it all
having been here for a year are you guys
enjoying it yeah yeah there's been
i think i flip-flop a lot in the first
six months the first six months i was
like
i would i would have one week or i'm
like i hate it i plan to go back in two
months yeah yeah
obviously not yeah you know what i mean
like there's some weeks where i think
especially where i've i said this in my
video about
my my because i made a video uh about
one year living in japan
yeah i think the big point i i try to
mention was like you have to make
like you have to force yourself to like
actively go out your way to make friends
here yeah yeah
it is not a country where friends just
come along you don't just bump into
people and you're like
let's hang out it's like you actually
you have to go out of your way to do the
whole like
when are you free what's your calendar
like let's make the solid not a [ __ ]
thing let's do it otherwise
i'm not going to see anyone for two
weeks yeah you guys right yeah yeah and
like having this podcast has really
helped because
before it was like okay we might hang
out every day yeah but then we also
might not see each other for like a week
and a half yeah
and then i realized i haven't left the
house in four days [ __ ] i'm starting to
feel lonely and i live
i live alone and i've never lived like
alone alone like never
because i've always had a roommate i've
always had a roommate or something and
and i didn't realize like how much
i like relied on that to like kind of
keep me a little bit sane
yeah um because you know sometimes my
[ __ ] roommate
uh zeno i love you but yeah you drive me
up the wall right but that's not that's
also that's also not like her fault it
was like just a thing of that that comes
with just having a roommate
eventually you just you live with
someone long enough you're like i
[ __ ] hate
just the little thing that you do and i
have no idea why yeah
and i thought i could live alone and
then i like one week into living alone
i'm like [ __ ] it's quiet in here oh yes
i was so [ __ ] depressed when i
started living alone here right like
before like arki moved in with me i was
like [ __ ] man i've been out of the house
in two weeks i'm so [ __ ] lonely right
now
and like am i am i the only true
introvert
i mean here i like my time alone don't
get me wrong right like i like my time
online but there's only
so much time i like alone before i'm
like
i require the touch of a human oh no i'm
i i i'm the same because i remember
before i moved to japan i basically
lived alone for like
uh like three four months yeah um
because uh sydney was in america at the
time
and we were sorting out visa stuff for
japan so there was just like
like a fair few month period where my
only social life would be when we'd be
able to like hang out in london
um and i don't know if it's just because
i've been in a relationship for like
four years
it was just like it was just it was just
like nice having
like just just living alone um and just
seeing
friends and seeing people when i wanted
to um because i guess the big difference
between japan and when i was living in
england is that
i could see someone whenever i wanted to
in england if i really wanted to yeah
you know what i mean
you could just mess with me yeah let's
hang out yeah exactly exactly i feel
like if it was
if it was the case of you know i don't
know when i'm going to see someone next
then i would be a way more lonely
um well that's why i'm like constantly
just like filling in plans like ahead of
you yeah yeah
yo you want to hang out you want to hang
out you want to hang out late otherwise
you're gonna find yourself in this kind
of like dead space of just no
interaction whatsoever yeah because like
when i first moved here and i didn't
really have anything
in my house and uh yeah i would just go
on tinder dates just because i was
lonely
yeah yeah i didn't like it sounds so sad
but you know
you know anything to do i would just go
to your your house but then i felt bad
you know because i didn't want to go to
their house every day and be like hey
guys
i know you didn't mind but i also didn't
like i felt like i was intruding
right so and it was just sad you know
and uh it took me a while to get used to
it and getting used to being alone
that sounds so sad [ __ ] it everyone
i mean living alone sorry being alone
i just have to get used to just being
you know in my shoulder
just crying no i i've i figured it out
now i figured how to have a healthy
balance of everything
but it took me a while because i did i
wasn't used to it right i always had
someone in my house that i could always
be like yo
you want to watch tv you know so is this
your subtle way of asking
us to come to your house please
no no no so like okay so we're going
back to our like original [ __ ] topic
of this video of like
online friends and everything when did
you guys realize that online friends
just
wasn't enough you couldn't feel that
whole
that having real physical friends that
you can see
like after i had like a really healthy
friend group
i think like like irl friend group yeah
yeah after you have like an actually
good irl friend group that like
you just you would rather hang out with
more than like anyone yeah i feel like
there's no going back
yeah yeah i i feel that as well because
i found my i found like my first proper
true friend group
like at the age of like 23 24 that's
when it kind of started
and i remember like my mom had like
[ __ ] up my entire perception
because my mom had raised me for like
18 years to be like don't give a [ __ ]
about your high school friends
your real friends for life your actual
real friends will come in university
so i go to you i go to university and i
just i'm just there with like my
housemates my coursemates
i'm just looking around i'm just like i
hate everyone around me
i feel like mike wazowski's just like
where are the friends yeah it's just
like
where are the friends mum why would you
lie to me mum
why would you lie to me so yeah i'm not
in contact with like anyone from like in
my university days
like some more so in my high school days
where university was lost
university was just like a [ __ ]
cesspool
where i was yeah i definitely i
definitely have more in contact with my
high school friends than i do my uni
friends
yeah like not sad i don't have any uni
friends like i have you know some of my
uni friends are [ __ ]
best friends forever but yeah yeah i
don't know like i think that whole thing
of like oh don't worry about high school
because there won't be a friend for like
i think it's kind of [ __ ] yeah i
think you'll you'll know if you've made
a friend for life yeah yeah yeah exactly
so i think it's like
there is no designated time when you
will make friends for life
it all happened along the way but i
remember like
finding my first friend group and now i
was just realizing oh
so i don't have to pretend to be someone
likeable to be around you guys because
you just
you guys just kind of like me for the
person i am yeah and that was just like
so mind blowing for me
what the [ __ ] is that all about yeah
cause it's just like having friends that
are like just like
you know even though there's like a lot
of a lot of people it's just like
everyone's there to help each other like
if you're having a low point
it's the whole philosophy of god you're
a [ __ ] but i love you yeah you know
is that yeah you know and just like
mates that are just there for you like
regardless of like you know what's going
on
yeah and i i really really really value
that yeah and uh
it's a shame as well because i'm i
[ __ ] hate texting so much
i absolutely despise texting yeah same
here and i pretty much the only people i
text
are like people i know that i'm going to
meet up with that i'm like yo
when when we're meeting up what's
happening you know like or it's like
business or anything but outside of that
i avoid it like the plague
because i just hate it why do you hate
it i just it doesn't feel genuine and it
takes so long
it's i'm like i'd rather have a 30
minute call than text for like a whole
day back and forth all right yeah yeah
same here like i mean i'm sure you both
know i'm [ __ ] awful at replying to
worse bro and that's because like i it
takes for me it takes like so much
mental energy to like
be i get it i can look at notifications
that i just i just have to like
have a dedicated time when i check
messages otherwise one i just get
distracted from whatever i'm doing
and i i much rather i i value so much
having like a
just an in-person or like an invoice
like actual communication because
there's so much that i can't communicate
when it's just during text that i just
i just rather talk to people i feel
i feel like a lot of you know a lot of
context is
almost lost as well when you're just
texting as well yeah like a lot it can't
be
like all the emotions can't be like you
know portrayed properly yes
um yeah and you know i kind of realized
as well that the
the friends you'll have in life the ones
that like i might not text right now
yeah like the real friends are the ones
where it doesn't matter i i don't
[ __ ] need to text them yeah like even
for a year or two
i go back and it's exactly exactly the
same it's exactly the same the way i see
is like it's kind of like a family
reunion yeah yeah i mean
and i didn't i didn't fully understand
the term
where i was just like friends of the
family you choose until i had a proper
friend group yeah
i was just like i i remember hearing
that for like my entire life and
thinking that's such a [ __ ] term
that's like this like cheesy disney
movie
that isn't actually real it's a [ __ ]
urban myth it's a [ __ ] urban legend
you know yeah yeah
it wasn't the destination it was the
friends we made along the way
so with that being said yeah back to the
the question at hand which was
how are you going to stay in japan what
do you think what do you think boys
because i think
right now my main thing is that like at
the end of the day
with all my gripes that i had and i i've
made them very known as the comments
like to point out that they think i
despise japan i'm very critical of
everything in life
yeah and uh at the end of the day japan
the standard of living is just much
higher at the moment
especially especially when you're
british you just learn to complain about
all the little yeah
yeah a lot of people just think that i i
really see a lot of comments like
connor's so [ __ ] rude about japan i'm
like no i'm just pretty no it's just
being real bro
it's just people just being brilliant we
complain about everything yeah
okay here's a question to you guys so we
all are living in the place
that is not where we were born did you
always
know that you would move out of your
home country and live somewhere else
yeah absolutely i like cause like at
least for me
i moved out of the house that i was born
in
yeah so i never moved until i moved out
of my home so
i've been living in that like my parents
house for like 21
years straight and i was just like yeah
it's home but yeah it's also like
you know you go home and you just see
the same view out of the window every
day
right yeah i need i need i need
something else i i love my home don't
get me wrong yeah but
i think especially because i was so
active online from such a young age
yeah yeah i became so aware like
globally of other different places right
right right and then it just made me
curious yeah yes i remember
yeah going back to my [ __ ] mum it was
just i remember like
when i was a kid i was just like mom i'm
telling you this now
love england's but i'm going to move out
three-year-old
like no seriously i was i was like you
know between like when when i was like
going from a kid to a teenager i [ __ ]
knew that i would like move out of
england eventually
and i was like mom don't take us
personally i'm just going to move back
i'm gonna i'm not gonna be in the
country my mom was like sure
sure bets
okay son whatever you say and i remember
when i told her hey mom i'm just gonna
like [ __ ] move to thailand for a few
years she was like surprise pikachu face
like
nani like oh you you were actually
serious all these years
yeah because like not that i don't love
england but i
one i wanted to experience like
different cultures and everything since
i was a [ __ ] kid
and two like i i don't know it's
i was always in my head i was always
thinking that there was this perfect
place to live
that wasn't the place that you were from
because everywhere else seemed so exotic
right
and everything and like the more i move
around the less idea
i have about where i truly want to
[ __ ] settle down
it's it's it's really weird right
because you especially if you live
like stay in the place for like any
substantial amount of time
you see all the great things that that
are there and you also see the bad
things there's no [ __ ] perfect place
right and the more the more you move
around the more you realize there is no
perfect place so
yeah well you got to make that decision
of hey where what is what is actually
best for me you know
legit when between the ages of like 12
and 16 i thought america was the perfect
place
i thought america was i really i really
wanted to live in america yeah
all my life until like age and probably
actually until like i moved to japan i
still like before that i was like i kind
of still want to go to america man
i don't know always since young age i'd
always been exposed to american culture
i always spoke with americans online
yeah and i just really loved their style
of doing things
yeah i love how [ __ ] crazy they are i
don't know i think i think it's because
for me it's like i didn't really like
interact with any americans
i think it's a thing right because i'm
yeah like literally from age 12
i've been chatting with people online
always voice chatting like
my parents for some reason didn't stop
me and most people
and most of the online friends you got
were just from america right yeah
yeah god i miss those days now it's all
[ __ ] memes and bad teeth and tuesday
youtube yep